now if the Gomer as my spear see I say I
don't know man
welcome to turbo dismount part 3
there's some new maps and some new
vehicles and I wanted to check it out
with you miss so now you can select your
head what does that do what anguish
mother [ __ ] do you speak what what
what what it says but I don't have a
picture like this and my computer
oh wow that's so weird all right let's
get the real Bob I said Bob not boobs
this is Bob and it's true his form Bob
don't give me that chin don't look at me
that way Bob all right let's play some
actual level so three new ones I think
let's start with this one so here we are
the dabrander beds and there's our hero
Bob also known as Tom Chris in disguise
great alright so that is bird cage oh
cool
that's not a bad shape all right
the great thing about this is that Bob
loves hanging on to [ __ ] so this should
not be a problem
gah Bob just hang on to that should have
hang on to the [ __ ] and step stop it
it's not funny it's not funny pig shut
up Ryback sorry he looks so happy too so
the point of these game is to get as
many points by doing as much damage to
Bob as possible let's try some new poses
that's pretty kinky
Bob loves his balls fried it loves it
look at it you dirty [ __ ] Bob I think it
makes the car go faster actually I'm not
sure though I'm pretty sure Bobby's got
castrated hey boss
Bob don't give it Bob don't give me that
hey look I love you I will never let you
go I will never okay that [ __ ] is dead
skate skate skate skate er Bob - see you
later Bob he wasn't good slamming on his
guitar I don't listen to everybody I
don't know the lyrics
alright let's check out what is called
and see parking light chicken parking
best parking i'll bought so much let's
see if we can go underneath it trust me
Batman
this is gonna go great okay let's plug
this tricycle that can't be that hard
right doing it
alright new mat loop-the-loop baby
you're excited Bob I'm sure you can do
it trust fate it's like Pokemon anything
you set your mind to you can
now that's poured yeah that's porn Oh
that weird [ __ ] that comes out of my
mouth
see now you're thinking a porn in that
that happens all right let's give Bob a
proper proper me at me via whatever you
can do it I believe in you and Santa
Claus so that means I don't believe in
you
Who am I kidding Santa is awesome oh
[ __ ] you did it Bob good Congrats hey oh
no oh no
oh he seems pretty chill about it he's
like yeah I'll be on my way
hey Paco Tuesday I'm sorry Bob here you
go you get to ride the pin car oh damn
that would oh nevermind you thought I
was a bob no I'm an engine remember what
I said Bob anything you [ __ ] can you
believe it whatever just do it come on
Bob don't give up oh you gave up skate
skate skate skate Oh Bob
see you later Bob he wasn't good enough
for her I [ __ ] loved her Levine okay
hey that's pretty smooth what is this oh
cool so you can download maps in shape
let's do that I got a ton of maps let's
check this one out
oh that looks interesting hi Bob
let's go you can do it but just do it
no don't check it you push it come on
goddamn this time you better not escape
oh it's a gun it is it gun it
alright you made the first one what
about second one eye now you're
basically [ __ ] I bet I swear to god
that looked like his penis I'm not being
a part Mary not for Bob at least Oh
there has to be some way to do it come
on Bob okay let's go with the tractor I
don't know why I called him tractor
that's right I think there is a tractor
gah Bob yeah good job on your win
nothing [ __ ] I know you have many
reasons nice to trust me but I want you
to know that no matter what happens I
hope you die oh damn
still fighting oh never mind I don't
know how to say this in a nice way Bob
but you're gonna [ __ ] die and I'm
gonna like it
oh don't worry about it gets better
oh damn where's his head oh there it is
say what you wanted my bob but it has a
godly ass oh damn what is this oh it's
first-person beautiful legs nothing can
go wrong
beautiful weather shut up again I got
yebin oh [ __ ]
everything went it's it's at my ass i
press that's all for me if you like if
you like my face no no one's gonna like
that but anyway
subscribe over today zebras tomorrow
with a new episode that be res stay
awesome